foreign
newly released body camera footage shows
a suspect to fire his weapon straight
into the air before an officer involves
shooting
the incident happened in Dallas Texas on
May 6th just after three o'clock that
morning dispatch received a call for an
active shooter on the city's South Side
Witnesses reported the suspect
53-year-old Chris Green had pointed a
gun at someone and fired it into the air
pressure vehicles
body camera video shows officers
arriving on the scene
hey get down on the ground hey get down
on the ground
hey Custer stay back stay back
hey look you're not in any trouble get
down on the ground
hey get down on the ground
get down on the ground green can be
heard yelling as officers call for him
to get down
he's on his way get down to the ground
hey he's on his way listen to me listen
to me he's on his way get down on the
ground right now
hey goodbye
hey
he's on his way video shows green ignore
the officer's commands before firing a
gun straight into the air
keep your hands up nope nope nope
he's got a gun in his hand
he just shot him
body camera video from another
responding officer shows a different
angle of the moment
[Music]
no no no
oh God
don't fucking put it at me all right
don't fucking
pointed put it down put it down
officers then run after green who heads
toward a car stopped at a traffic light
oh second is
Let's Go cover code three
over there
too
hey get down on the ground
when green points his weapon at officers
they open fire
[Applause]
after this officers run to take green
into custody
video then shows First Responders giving
Green Medical Aid
s
green was taken to the hospital and is
now in stable condition he faces
multiple charges and the
officer-involved shooting including
deadly conduct and criminal mischief the
shooting itself is still under
investigation by the Dallas Police
Department and the Dallas County
District Attorney's Office reporting for
long crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie